hey guys it's Jenna here I'm currently
in Bali in this beautiful villa and to
be honest I don't even want to get out
of my bed so today I want to challenge
you to do 100 ab exercises without
getting out of bed yep you can do these
exercises while lying in bed you can do
it first thing in the morning or before
the end of your day 10 exercises 10
repetitions per workout and you will be
working your entire core your upper abs
lower abs your obliques your lower back
basically we want to tighten and
strengthen this entire midsection so get
your body ready and it's time to lie in
bed so the first workout is going to be
roll up and twist okay so you are still
lying in bed having a really good rest I
want you to lengthen your arms and just
slowly roll up and stretch twist your
sight and back down good so 10 wraps per
workout roll up through your abs working
lengthen twist and touch up and down
good
so remember 10 reps for workout fuel
your upper abs working and back down
nice up touch touch and strengthen and
down good again up reach touch touch
lengthen and back down so this will also
really wake your body up good touch
touch twist and back down this is a
really good way to engage the entire
core muscles first thing in the morning
or if you don't have time you can always
do it before heading to bed again touch
touch really feel your obliques and down
three more guys up whew touch touch and
reach and go back down two more up touch
touch in order to keep your leg straight
I want you to point a toes and really
engage your core to bring your body up
and to lengthen your spine and now just
roll down good while still lying in bed
we want to do full crunches okay so
hands by your side we want to crunch up
hug your legs extend open up and crunch
hug your legs and extend good that's it
so ten reps hug and extend look at your
knees hug and extend very nice again hug
extend stretch out hug x10 so you only
want to bring your legs as looook as you
can without arching your back too much
for more work x10 last three hug x10
last two hug x10 last one curl up and
extend very nice point your toes bring
your legs down and now let's just bring
our body up okay so I want you to keep
your elbows on the bed and we want to do
half v-tex okay this is my favorite
workout some of you have done this
workout in my previous video so toes
pointed forward leg straight bring your
legs up and just crunch - that's it
three as soon as you can for good
five crunch and really few low abs six
seven open your chest eight whoa nine
one more and ten good very nice so same
thing we want to still keep our elbows
on the bed and we want to imagine that
you have a pillow in the middle and I
want you to just go over the pillow but
no knees slightly go over and just go
over so left and right is one and left
alright is to - good three over over
nice for good so keep your upper body
upright and straight and just move your
leg left to right six
seven bend your knees slightly over
eight last to nine last one and ten over
over and just bring it straight down and
just stretch it out slightly very
quickly okay and now we want to do
reverse crunches so lie back down place
your hands just by your side or under
your butt slightly and we want to bring
your legs in and crunch up and down so
if you want you can keep your leg
straight or you can bend your knees
slightly
crunch in good three crunch four so this
will really work on your lower abs five
push your butt up slightly six push good
seven oh my god my heart rate is also
pumping eight up oh nine up and ten up
very good now just bring your licks down
okay and we want to do ring shield wiper
so basically stretch your arms up out by
your side and imagining that you're a
wiper and you want to clean your car
windshield so it licks up just drop it
to the left and go over and drop it to
the right and use your obliques to pull
it back to the left and pull it back to
the right good so left or right is 1/3
nice pull it back
for good don't drop your legs entirely
control it
five up wipe six up and wipe seven up
and wipe get three more eight you're
doing very well
and you're doing all this in your bed
nine up and one more 10 and the other
side oh my god and I'll just hug your
knees just bring your knees together
just relax it up slightly okay give it a
good shake and just stretch it out
slightly a little bit more before moving
on to the next workout
ready next workout is going to be
Cesar's so same thing you can lie by
your side and all I want you to do is
just bring right leg up reach and crunch
in okay again
left hand red is one crunch - good big
scissors three crunch really bring and
reach four so what you're doing you're
not just working on your apps but you're
also stretching your hamstrings out five
good point your toes 6m7 rich-rich
eight last two nine last one ten and
just stretch it out and just drop both
legs the next workout is going to be 4
times app so it's about the same workout
but instead of reaching and crunch it up
we want to just lie our upper body down
hands by side and just go left right
down down up up down down good that's -
that's free okay good so you really have
to control your little apps and really
work on your lower abs to make sure that
you know you don't want to drop your
entire legs next right right down down
combine your knees slightly up
down down this workout would get tough
especially when it's two words the end
up up down down up up down down two more
up up down down up up down down oh my
god
oh I can feel my lower abs burning oh
and the rain is actually pouring right
now and the final two workout is going
to be flat the kicks and also plank so
guys again do you know what lying down
is not easy so just lie down and we want
to do 10 flutter kicks left and right
one two three four five really engage
six seven eight nine ten and finally
let's turn over and get into a rocking
plank okay so up instead of just holding
the plank I want you to rock forward and
back ten times one two three four five
six seven eight really keep your body
straight nine and ten now you can just
drop I just relax for a little bit oh so
that's your 100 apps challenge while
lying in bed do this workout for the
next four to six weeks and I can assure
you that you will get a stronger and
also tighten midsection if you enjoy
this workout if you feel that your app
is burning then be sure to share this
workout like this video and subscribe to
my youtube channel for new weekly videos
all the best guys